[Music]
i am so honored that jeanette mccurdy is
on the show today y'all would have to be
living under a rock or snorting a lot of
rock to not have heard of her new book
i'm glad my mom died it is absolutely
it is brilliant it is so well written it
is covers everything from her childhood
trauma to her
stockholm syndrome narcissistic
relationship with her mother um uh
growing up too fast in hollywood which
is oddly relatable
you know most people aren't child stars
but the way that she writes it you can
apply everything that she's going
through to your own life and be able to
still uh
oddly be able to look in the mirror with
this book even though it's such a unique
experience and then uh she outlines in
such a perfectly funny yet you know
honest
not funny as in minimizing it just
perfectly captures um
the aftermath of uh her struggle with
eating disorders addiction um etc and
how she picked up all the pieces and has
uh transmogrified into a complete
superhero i am going to just real quick
air my little insecurity about this
interview
um
this just wouldn't be a good for you
podcast if i didn't waste everyone's
time with a bunch of apologies for
things that no one's even gonna notice
um that i did wrong but
she came in and um i didn't know that i
had to get her she had to go to pasadena
after something so i just we were
hanging out before because she we had
talked and she said she was a little
nervous and i was like oh let's hang out
before
and i
then i kind of felt rushed during the
interview because i
was throwing a little bit of a curveball
and i also felt like after watching all
of her interviews like people had done
such little i don't know i'm not going
to judge other look just because i'm an
award-winning pulitzer prize-winning
journalist who was like highly trained
in journalism i can't judge all these
other weirdos on
nbc and cbs but
i um
feel like she was telling her story over
and over and to people that didn't
really understand what she had been
through and having had my own uh abuse
as a child and eating disorders etc i
just i felt this
desire to take the weight off her having
to say it all and i also didn't want her
to have to recap her own book which i
can't stand when people do that read the
book so i was like i wasn't gonna so i
just feel like i talked a little bit too
much but that's just me
um and uh
i just wanna hear her talk forever and
she will be coming back by hell or hard
water please enjoy the brilliant
jeanette
mccurdy
[Music]
no pressure but you're a hero you too so
congrats on that thank you thank you did
we get that do we get her saying that in
the camera did we get that when he's a
hero when he's an absolute hero
i'm just so happy for you i'm so
inspired by you your book i could not
put it down it is a masterpiece you are
a brilliant writer oh thank you so much
that means so much coming from you can
you just walk me through your style
because it is ferocious um i when i
started doing the book promotion i was
like i want to look
like
you know a little put together so the
thing that felt put together to me was
callers so i just
and i was like but i also want to be fun
i want to be fucking boring so then i i
started doing like sports bras over uh
over caller
a
she looks like a superhero from the
future
and it is so like you doesn't she look
like like a guardian angel from the
future i'm influenced like i'm taking
notes i'm wearing this tomorrow what was
the the woman from the matrix that was
um carrie ma carrie anne moss
i don't know i only character
who is carrion uh morbius morph
menstruations trinity trinity trinity
you look like do you know what i'm
saying
yeah
is that the one who's in love with
canneries and then at the end okay okay
oh probably yeah yeah she was in memento
remember memento did you ever see that
movie i did recently yeah it's all such
an incredible movie yeah um carrie anne
moss let's talk about her
you know what this interview is going to
be about us our take on carrie and moss
you have nothing interesting to talk
about right so what do we have
so i'm kind of glad you're here is kind
of toward the tail end of this press
tourer
i am too because i thought i knew that
i'd have a lot of fun here i've had i've
enjoyed the press so far more than i've
enjoyed pressing anything else i have
but um you sound skeptical
you know what it is i've been watching
all your presents and i have some notes
please tell me please let's hear it not
on you i have some notes on some of
these people that like did the least
like every i guess it just drives me
nuts when someone interviews someone and
hasn't watched the other interviews
they've done so then you go oh i'm going
to ask all the questions that haven't
been asked
i will say you and i were texting about
one and that did happen a while ago um
and i i have feelings about that one i
have complicated feelings about that one
but the press run for the book
specifically i have felt very like
they've asked
you know thoughtful questions but i was
excited to come here because i thought
it'd be more much more fun uh and and
i i do think there are elements of the
book that are funny and and i feel like
people have
have been maybe hitting more of the like
the dramatic elements and i think that
also
you know and i relate so much to
the way your brain works and we'll get
into um why but
perfectionists you know and people that
you know want to get things right it's
interviews sometimes are hard because
it's like i'm going to be perfect but
you're not
so
you could
i i would love for you to struggle with
perfectionism a little more
how do you feel how do you feel about
the perfectionist um label
do you have is it
um well since i'm perfect i'm fine with
it
i'm i'm actually fine with it because i
think for me i had such a fraught
relationship with perfectionism so long
and once i changed the definition of
what perfect is i'm okay with it
so perfect doesn't mean you know what i
think the toxic version of it you know
yeah what is it what is it how have you
reframed it um uh perfectionism to me is
just looking like you
it's something that um
i yeah i don't really use that word i
have to be honest there are like some
toxic words that just aren't in my
vocabulary just for me personally yeah
um i don't use words like healthy
uh i don't instead of saying like that's
not healthy we say like that's not
helpful
um we don't use the word perfect because
it's just not
use it as like oh perfect great it's a
three o'clock perfect like can say it
like that but in terms of like oh this
is perfect or i look per like there's
none of that i don't use that word yes
and i don't use the word happy
ooh it's too vague and childish for me
like i just i don't my brain doesn't
understand what the definition is and if
i don't know the definition of something
i get confused about it hmm when
someone's like are you happy i'm like
what does that mean yeah yeah i don't
know
i don't know what that word is so for me
i go like when i have integrity when i
feel pride at the end of the day that's
when i feel fulfilled and satisfied i
think that's happiness but if it means
like skipping through fields in a dress
with like pigtails i've never
done that right you know so it's like
too big so i just have to use words that
are like really specific to my brain so
i don't sure spin out i remember i had a
thing with uh my therapist where i i had
some reservation about using like softer
language
i feel like i speak in extremes that's
definitely my tendency and being like i
hate this i love that i whatever as
opposed to and she was she was trying to
have me like reframe to oh i'm not i i
don't particularly like that just just
language that would help me soften
toward myself and have more self
compassion i thought it was so fucking
lame at first i didn't want to do it i
thought if i if i hate something i want
to say that i fucking hate this if i
loathe this part of myself i want to say
load this part of myself why do i need
to soften it uh but now i'm at a place
where i do i find value in it and i find
that it has helped me to be more
self-compassionate um but it's been a
long a long road and i definitely still
sometimes want to just fucking like say
the thing you know say the intense thing
or
feel the the full
in order to like feel the full intensity
of it but
i appreciate softer language now because
it's because it's also just about
getting specific you know and
if you get too specific you
can't blame
someone else which is a very uh
cozy anesthetic
and usually if it's hysterical it's
historical so it's like i hate this
table like
it has nothing to do with the table so
that's how we get specific like what's
why why do you hate this why does this
table have so much control over you and
your emotions something that it should
be should not have a charge oh well it
makes me uncomfortable because okay well
because it's it's too high and i'm short
okay so what's going on there oh i i'm
i'm uncomfortable oh i'm uncomfortable
about my height oh this table holds a
mirror up to one of my insecurities
i okay
damn oh my god the table had nothing to
do with it i do like this table
so that i have to break that down
because i think
when you move through the world with
people i hate this person and you're
like
no i don't know this person so how could
i hate them
what is what mirror is this person
holding up about what i hate about
myself or what is this person reminding
me of life it's annoying but then life
gets a lot less
uh violently against you you know this
reminds me can we talk about the first
time we met yes um so i came here
a year and a half a while ago during
coped and i was so
anxious about meeting you i've been a
fan of yours for a long time and i felt
like like even talking about the
anxiousness from then like on the way
over was like fuck what am i gonna say
um how am i gonna how is it gonna be and
then uh and i got here and it was like
my worst nightmare i don't think i said
a word to you for two and a half hours
i was frozen against a wall everybody
else was talking everybody else was
having fun uh it was
it i
have like nightmares about it was really
really bad
like for weeks i was like how am i gonna
what should i text her an apology i was
like trying to i worked through in
therapy and i like didn't know what to
do i was like i think when he comes
hates me i don't know what to do about
it i feel awful like i wasn't a good
reflection of myself um so i'm glad to
be here now and i hope to redeem myself
that's my goal and i'm so excited
because i
found out you were here like a couple
days later
esther was like so jeanette mccurdy and
i'm like oh i love her i hear she has
this amazing podcast where she talks
about what she's been doing she's like
yeah she was at your house the other
night i was like
what
i was like oh the girl i just remember
you being like in a sleeping bag or like
a blanket like i was like oh is that who
that was like
i didn't put it together i was like
wrapped in a jam blanket yeah and then
of course classic i'm like well i guess
she doesn't like me she shouldn't talk
to me like who goes to someone's house
and doesn't say hi i guess i'm not
hospitable i guess maybe i was being a
bitch does she think i'm a bitch so
we're both doing the same thing
i feel like when i'm around uh
particularly women
that have very
um
strong kind of magnetic personalities
and are especially funny women i
completely love those letters
i read your book and i was like oh i get
why she might be a little triggered by
me
i feel like i suddenly don't i i it's
when i'm around like just as shy like i
have a couple friends that are very shy
and i feel like i become sort of the
more outgoing one in those in those
environments but otherwise i completely
shut down and unfortunately this one
feels more like truthful but the other
one feels more like overcompensating
this feels more like myself but so far
i'm talking this seems like a good start
a good like direction
i feel like also
i have a i have women terrify me realize
i grew up um and we'll get into your
book in a second and we're getting into
it but i don't want to do what everyone
else has done which is just make you go
like defend the title
if you have a problem with this title
you haven't read the book like if
someone opens with like this title it's
like you didn't read it let her let her
leave read it and have her come back
like it's just so it drives me nuts and
there was also the one woman show which
i want to ask you about yeah are you
gonna do something with that i i hope so
you know i actually i i'd like to to go
back into it and do it again um it was i
that was something that i was fucking
terrified about doing but i was like i
tried to ask my friends to do it in wigs
i was gonna have each like a bunch of my
different friends do it and just have
their interpretation i thought it'd be
like a fun spin on it and and one
volunteers tribute
to play your mom
one of them was like you're crazy like
this you can't have your friends do it
like i love you but that's just a
terrible idea and like i need to tell
you it's a terrible idea um and i was
like you should do have a child actor do
it oh my god
directed
the level oh my god
um i was so nervous before doing that i
was like dry heaving on a street corner
and felt like oh god i can't do this and
then i thought well this is really bad
because i really care about talking
about you know mental health and and
that whole what that has but man
situation one woman show you did perform
it i never stopped i did perform it i
did perform it so what what felt great
about it was that i i feel like i got
over my performance anxiety through
doing the show i felt like i made it
less about oh i stopped saying oh i need
to do a 10 of 10 performance i just need
to sink in feel what i'm saying and try
and connect with people so i started
choosing three to four people that i'd
try and kind of perform the specific
monologues to or this song it's a
musical or the songs too and i found
that so grounding and so helpful because
it said i wasn't suddenly being like a
caricature of myself and like do it
hitting the beats too hard or like
trying to get laughs in place like it
just felt like okay i can just like be
myself and trust that
it's it's going to be it's going to be
dynamic it's not always it doesn't
always need to be at such a
heightened um place and that that helped
me a lot and and really kind of like
soothed my nerves so that beforehand i
wasn't going out dry heaving like i was
i was able to find
some enjoyment in it it was still
stressful but some enjoyment but you
might make something from it either a
show or a special or something maybe so
i'm i'm open to it i'm also trying to
this is such a like cliche thing but i'm
trying to like enjoy and appreciate
what's happening with the book and not
get too ahead of myself because that is
my instinct my instinct just to go okay
well what am i doing
um but just trying to go okay this is
really cool and this is really special
and how can i appreciate
this um so it's a lot of like walks and
listening to posting alone and trying to
just like appreciate and then the
anxiety comes in like okay we're
appreciating right now we're
appreciating but i say it kind of like
tensely because i'm i'm this is this is
always going to be my sort of angle and
you know what you've been through is um
like harrowing it's really hard to make
me like gasp like it's hard to make me
gasp you know um i've been in i've
talked about um allen on aca
codependence recovery for almost 14
years and you hear everything you've
said you know um
when you get a gasp in the room there's
this
sort of bittersweet like i win like i'm
the most traumatized in here and uh you
hear you know horrific things about
entrenched relationships parents that
are narcissists you know borderlines um
bipolar uh alcoholic abuse all kinds of
you know really sick abuse and
entrenchment and um so i i kind of went
in like
i was truly like
gasping uh
and and there's some things in here that
truly like broke my heart when it for me
i'm always able to uh yeah but that made
her stronger and that oh she got this
superpower from that you know so there's
some things in here that were you know
really uh
maybe truly speechless and um but at the
same time
as you're going through this and
the reason i bring up a show or whatever
i'm obsessed with alchemizing our trauma
into something positive supplement
sublimating it into something to where
you're able to go at some point you know
what thank god that happened yes because
that's the only way to you know move
forward for me personally to be able to
get to a point where i'm like oh my god
i have this like awesome advantage
because all that stuff happened to me
like that was a gift that was a
superpower like thanks dad thanks mom it
took me a while to see
all of these tools that you gave me that
a lot of people do not have and so i'm
just curious
willist acknowledging the trauma and the
very real injuries which
we can dig into but also read the book
um
do you look back and go
think about any maladaptive behaviors or
coping mechanisms that you developed
willist going through this abuse that
now you look back and you're like ugh i
have this advantage a lot of people
don't have hyper vigilance
absolutely i was so wired to like my
mom's every
flinch every emotional whim every
i just felt like i could read her better
than anybody else in the house i felt
like nobody else kind of knew like what
was dictating mom's mood so it would
just be like this shock of like why is
she yelling i'm thinking why is she
yelling two hours ago dad wasn't didn't
call when he said he was gonna call then
grandpa walked in and he stepped on this
on the stand on the floor so that set
her off then she's like a little more
aggravated by the time the boys put
their cereal bowls in the sink and they
have the milk and they didn't empty out
the milk like she likes and i'm thinking
it makes sense this all makes sense yeah
like why are you guys not seeing what
what seems so obvious to me um and in
therapy for a while i found that as such
a i thought it was such a weakness such
a frustrating thing like chip on my
shoulder something that i had to deal
with
um and now and something that i had to
overcome and now i feel like there's a
lot of value in it i think it's it made
me more emotionally in tune and i think
it's made me
pick up on cues
from others in a way that's hopefully
hopefully leads to more empathy um more
understanding i've tried to
you know
help hopefully it leads to more
compassion um but i i'm that's i'm not
always the most compassionate person but
but on a good day
and i i absolutely think of it as a
strength now what do you have one is
there something comes around for you i
was just gonna say for when you know
because i know you're gonna be directing
and all i was thinking about was like oh
this ability to number one you know it's
all about motives shape-shifting people
pleasing
anticipating people's needs mothering
martyring micromanaging if the
motive is to control someone anesthetize
yourself get out of your own shit so you
don't have to think about yourself judge
someone or the basis for all of that you
know judging micro margin uh
micromanaging but all that yes is
you can't handle this on your own
i'm gonna do it for you because you
can't you're not capable it's basically
what you're saying when you're quote
unquote helping people whatever um or
being nice nice isn't nice but when
you're directing
all of these
you know maladaptive
behaviors if the motives are i want to
make this great movie i want to help
this actor i want to help this
other person are going to come in so
handy because you're going to be able to
talk to a child actor yes differently
than you're going to talk to an adult
actor definitely then you're going to
talk to the grip definitely then you're
going to talk to chip yeah yes yeah
exactly
definitely
and then to be able to anticipate
people's needs in a good way you know so
i i think you i'm just so excited for
your career as a director having come
from this because you're going to have
so many superpowers that a lot of people
don't have
and
it's not i'm not psyched about how you
got those tools sure but you have them
yeah you know like are you in that place
now we're able to go like oh i have a
couple advantages that other people
don't have even though i didn't get to
have the child that i wanted i think the
i think the experience of directing is
what got me there honestly i directed a
i've directed like five short films and
some of them are a couple years back but
i remember being you know really
scared ahead of directing and thinking
oh am i going to be able to do it and i
felt so kind of over prepared with like
shot list but then you show up on the
day and things aren't what you expect
and the the window's not working or the
lights are like there's just so many so
much problem solving technical problem
solving that has to take place
um that i would lean on the crew for a
lot of the technical problem solving i
definitely have an opinion on what i
like things to be and
learn how to kind of articulate that
better but working with actors
oh my god i felt like oh my i'm good at
this like i'm really good at this i can
talk to them i can i can understand
their intentions i can hopefully help
them feel valued because sometimes my
experience as an actor was that i just
felt like a fucking puppet and people
were just like say the line like this
and it's like i don't want to say like
that but you're like trying to do their
exact line reading it's fucking annoying
um so trying to make it a little bit
more of a creative experience um but
also just being able to have the acumen
to
over analyze you know over analyzing
someone's thought process with your mom
is not ideal when it's this character
where it's your job to overanalyze
things and you're getting paid to over
analyze it's like okay i know how to do
this yes yes yes yes yes yes i just i
shouldn't be doing it with my primary
caretaker yeah this is a appropriate
place to be doing this 100
you know so i think there's that and
then um to answer your question yeah i
mean for me like my ability to
anticipate
problems is big like i can just feel
when the damocles sword is gonna drop i
can feel
uh when there's an elephant in the
living room i can feel tension and
usually be able to
anticipate someone's needs in a very
basic level because a lot of times it's
like do you need water do you need a nap
you know that was a big thing because i
had to take care of my caretakers as a
kid too you know and um
that's a big thing for me organization
preparation um you know
i grew up in a home that was like we're
always out of everything we could never
find the duct tape we never knew where
the advil was like i know where
everything is at all times and so like
people would say like over organized but
i'm like no this is i am prepared for
literally anything
earthquake flood like there's
i make sure
there are going to be no bumps that i
can control in the future you know so
there's definitely that um i have the
ability to shut down and disassociate in
a way that sometimes helps me i get very
clear in a time of crisis and i feel
very alive in a time of crisis and then
when things are calm i feel very anxious
same yes yes you know so i think that's
kind of a superpower i'm not the most
fun person at a party i'm kind of i'm
there to like handle if like the
electricity goes out or something breaks
like i'm just hoping something bad
happens so i could be useful because
that's where i shine
i am so bad at calm i'm so
bad at you know that i'm just kind of
waiting for a crisis to happen because
that's where i shine and then
i'm sort of waiting for the other shoe
to drop otherwise and then i
need to be useful um usefulness is how i
basically get drive my self-esteem my
productivity uh but usefulness to other
people so like when i go to something
i'm like how can i be useful can i help
with this can i help with that and if i
can have my motive not be
i know i'm unlovable unless i'm useful
to you it's just more like this is where
i can also
do it now and just enjoy it
but it's it's kind of a super power too
are there environments where you feel
like they're
what happens in environments where the
usefulness isn't
at right at your fingertips or if
there's if if
if you go on vacation was my thought
like if you go on vacation there's not
really a thing to do never happens when
was the last time it happened
uh it's just not for me
and that's okay i love that i don't
force myself to do anything i don't want
to do great and i don't shame myself for
not wanting and enjoying the things that
everyone else wants and enjoys
you know
i just i'm i really like doing things
for myself because look growing up
everything had a price
right well i did this for you i just did
that for you and i did this for you
there was always like score keeping of
like i'm hungry well i just got you this
it's like oh we're keeping score on
feeding your child like i didn't realize
there were only so many things i could
ask for a like basically in my home
there was um because there was uh
i'm trying to
not talk so much
how did this happen wait what do you
mean just in general yes why because i
have so many questions for you
what this is great what's what's the
what's the thought i'm gonna say just
one last thing okay one last thing and
then i'm gonna ask you these questions
okay let's talk more about talking about
what you want to talk about i'm now in a
shame spot because no my brain is going
like stop talking so much but we haven't
got to really like hang yes this is
great but there's a conversation for you
and i to hang off camera but everyone
just wants to hear you talk no i don't
think so
reading the youtube comments in my head
right now i think they're thrilled
so no what i've i've lost my train of
thought
um usefulness vacation
everything is keeping school yeah
growing up i grew up in a home where
there was uh alcoholic home which
alcoholic we all know now in order for
alcoholism to be to be present alcohol
doesn't have to be present any kind of
compulsive behavior where it wasn't a
choice it could be compulsive cleaning
compulsive cooking compulsive drinking
compulsive whatever sex addiction all
gambling all of it but there was not a
lot of space in my home because everyone
there was a lot of unrecovered alinonism
and alcoholism everyone was always very
busy everyone was always 10 minutes late
everyone was always running out of
something there was so little um
self-care going on that everyone was
always at capacity everyone was always
at their boiling point yeah if i ever
needed anything i was always the one
putting someone over the edge making
someone cry oh good now whitney needs a
water like it was always like it was
never worth asking for help because
there was you're always putting too much
on the other person you were always too
much of an emotional burden and because
my mother interpreted any kind of needs
i had as a criticism towards her or
something because you haven't
anticipated my need
she felt like i was shaming her just
asking for basic things so i learned in
early age do not go to her for help
you're just overwhelming her stressing
her out so just do it all yourself or
don't have needs at all you know so i
learned to self-deprive and i learned to
try to solve my own problems to the
point to where oh my god when there was
no heat in the house because we didn't
pay the bills instead of just saying i
need a sweater or can we turn the heat
up i would get dressed on the stove
every morning and caught on fire my
pajamas caught on fire oh my god but as
a child you don't know you're just
solving the problem yes in a way that
you you're like okay i'm cold if i ask
for a robe or if i ask for something i'm
gonna get yelled out or she's gonna feel
like she's a bad mom why don't you get
another mother well maybe i'll get hit
by a bus like you know so me asking for
things just
held a mirror up to the insecurities she
already had about being a bad mother so
i learned do it yourself to the point of
putting myself in danger you know quite
a bit wow um are your parents still
alive
my mom is in a nursing home my dad is
not
when did your dad pass away uh about
four years
oh incredibly recent they both had
strokes like 10 years ago yeah both had
strokes in the like
yeah
how was that for you were you like
look i'm doing great
you saw you saw my hair during the
pandemic i'm coping marvelously
grief's a motherfucker
um let me ask you though oh so here i
actually wrote mine down because i
didn't want to be the i have a bullshit
meter okay that is like i really am
grateful for yeah um
that's good i can like smell people's
like motives yeah yeah yeah you know
which i think is something you get yes
as a sexual abuse survivor alcoholic
home you're just like ah i don't trust
this person like adam that's just not
true um also uh i can remove myself i
can remove myself from situations in a
way that a lot of people find
sociopathic but with between my recovery
and what happened to me if i'm in a
situation that makes me uncomfortable
i'm just gone out of this like no
questions asked interesting no questions
asked i don't feel like oh anyone an
apology i don't make excuses i just
removed my just get out of there yeah i
relate to that also i i feel like i can
remove myself in a way that might people
might be confused by or think like well
what happened and i'm thinking well it's
very obvious what happened and i don't
necessarily owe that person an
explanation and this is what i need to
do to take care of myself so you know if
you're confused you're dumb
yeah
yeah
bat-bap break
we're now going to talk about rituals
symbiotic plus it contains two of the
world's most studied strains with over
350 publications of human clinical
trials we're not talking about these
ridiculous
fake
um
are we allowed to cursing ads
no no bullcrap artists who are like yeah
just take four grams of lion's mane and
then a little bit of garlic charcoal and
you can just eat a little gold just
swallow
you know what if you see a penny on the
ground just lick it that's how you'll
get your minerals and then maybe deep
throat some clay you're like what
medical school
did you go to
um so this is actual real doctors it is
more than a probiotic three and one with
clinically studied uh prebiotics
probiotics and the postbiotic to support
a balanced gut
microbiome most probiotics number one if
they're not refrigerated the right way
if they're not preserved the right way a
lot of the probiotics you're getting i
mean placebo effect is an effect but
like this is actual i've been through a
lot of um probiotics that are uh not
um effective yeah so ritual has been
doing my omegas um i've been taking
those for almost five years now and now
they have this um
symbiotic plus which is a total game
changer because i can't take on any more
capsules yeah and this is just one daily
capsule for simple streamlined gut
support um so synbiotic plus and ritual
are here to celebrate not hide like me
your insides there's no more shame in
your gut game that's why ritual is
offering my listeners well not mine well
sort of
that's why
this is called grace for you whoa that's
why ritual is offering goodness
that's why rituals offering whitney's
listeners ten percent off during your
first three mine visit ritual.com
whitney to start ritual or add symbiotic
plus to your subscription today stop
farting on the train back to the show i
had a question about the the burden
piece that's also that's something i
relate with a lot is it something do you
feel like you still do you have any of
that
like not wanting to be a burden that's
like that's one of my leading kind of
um that's like one of my main compasses
like okay how do i not be a burden in
this situation and learning how to
either ask for help or i now have a
really great team around me and learning
how to just trust that and not feel like
oh i have to do everything my own
because then i'm a burden if i don't
like that's that's
that all i'm assuming always be there in
some way for me do you feel that or is
it i find
i am being a burden if i can do
something for myself or want to do
something for myself but then ask
someone else to do it just because i'm
scared to i am being a burden that's
what i'm saying
so for me
it's just about getting real with myself
because if i'm going
if i try one time to log into something
yeah and then i'm like can you i don't i
am being a burden and then i'm like i
feel like i'm being a burden because i'm
asking someone to do this and i'm like
well also i gave up too soon because of
my own insecurity about getting
something wrong or my own impatience or
my own lack of time management because
i'm not running a tight allen on
self-care program so i i feel like a
burden because i am
oh
but no i'm saying but you know what i'm
saying acknowledge when i am doing
something out of insecurity and
immaturity and self-righteous
indignation of going like
i only go to people for things i
actually want and need them to do
something for and then the rest i do do
myself because i also take so much pride
in doing things myself and comfort
because i number one know what's going
to be done right number two i know
what's going to be done but so i don't
ask people to do things that aren't
appropriate yeah because if if i feel
like a burden that's information
either i am asking people for something
that isn't appropriate or i'm doing the
same thing over and over again and
expecting a different result or i'm
asking someone to do something that i
don't have faith they can actually
execute it anyway and i'm actually
making them a burden to me interesting
this reminds me of the thing we're kind
of talking about off-camera like when to
differentiate between oh this is my old
patterning and this is something that
um
is not necessarily the most uh relevant
to the situation versus oh this is
actually something that i need to work
on and and kind of navigating those cues
uh
and two things can be true at once yes
yes i can have um a you know in program
we say character defect i like to say
superpower because i think anything any
tool that you got any maladaptive
behavior or character defect or survival
mechanism whatever word or phrase works
best for you you got as a child in
response to a dysfunctional home in
order to survive that it worked really
well when you were a kid right and now
as an adult that's why we say adult
child of alcoholic it means you're still
using the survival strategies that
worked as a kid as an adult
and a lot of times it works a lot of
times it doesn't so some of them work
some of them don't or two things can be
true at once and sometimes they work and
sometimes they don't so i think that's
the hardest thing for people like us is
to stay out of the black and white
thinking of like this is always bad and
this is always good you know my
obsessive compulsive need to clean some
it's bad if i'm running 20 minutes late
but if it's it's good if it's something
i enjoy doing on a saturday morning for
fun and for free and i'm not doing it to
get uh to basically meet an internal
need yes right i'm not going to external
things for internal needs you know so as
long as i'm not doing it in order to
feel good about myself or in order to
um
anesthetize the fact that this thing
happened to me that i don't want to
confront so i'm just gonna pour it into
this as long as i'm like no i'm just
doing it for this reason what's my
motive yes i think it's really just
always about your motive so it's like if
i'm driving someone to the airport
because i feel like i have to because i
want them to like me because i'm worried
they'll abandon me if i don't and i want
to control them and i want them to owe
me
bad news but if i literally am like i'm
being of service because this person you
know and i enjoy doing it and i expect
nothing in return
and i'm not going to six months in six
months when they're late go but i drove
you to the airport that time if i'm not
sitting on it is to lord over them so
it's just about your motive you have to
be able to have a conversation with
yourself and go why am i doing this i so
appreciate how nuanced this is and how
like in the weeds of it all it is
because something that concerns me about
i i love that mental health is talked
about the way that it's talked about now
and is so
prevalent but it concerns me that it's
talked about in such a it feels to me
like it's talked about a lot of times in
a black and white way in a way that's
just the pendulum is going to keep
swinging it's going to be like well
self-care is too blank well toxic's too
bland and then it's like okay but
there's some there's more to it than
that there's it can't just be like
summed up in a in a headline it's not
that simple um i appreciate the way that
you're talking about it well i think
there's no one that's talking about
trauma in a way that is eventually
triumphant i'm into the like triumphant
effects of trauma because it's honestly
the only thing we can control at this
point and just because i've lived a lot
of my life as a victim doesn't mean i
have to identify for that at the rest of
my life i got chills oh my god you know
yeah so it's like i think that that is
what's missing people are so obsessed
with talking about their trauma but they
don't want to talk about like the
solutions for it how to alchemize the
trauma into something positive and how
to look at your
you know the wounds from your trauma as
superpowers yes you know because i don't
know if it's just because people want to
be addicted to like well you're
depressed and that's just your life now
and you're just depressed you have ocd
so i guess you just
that has to define you as someone who is
behind in some way and i like to go you
have this you know neurodiversity that
actually gives you an advantage in life
and these are actually your superpowers
and let's figure out how to like
befriend these
and there's some
you know protection mechanisms and you
know uh tools we got to get that we
should keep in the toolbox we probably
won't need again
but there's some that we can probably
bring out every now and then and then it
can give us like a little bit of a
gratitude for what happened
in a way but that gets me to your mom so
your mom do you feel like you haven't
i know this sounds in 10 years this
10 minutes this probably won't even hold
up but is do you feel like there's an
official diagnosis for her that's just a
working diagnosis
yes so i spoke with a couple therapists
about this and they
each uh three different people suggested
that she had a combination or all of the
above of borderline personality disorder
bipolar disorder and narcissistic
personality disorder um with they they
really
specified too that the the thing that's
really telling about narcissistic
personality disorder i mean i've looked
up the criteria and she's
quite it seems like she fits every
single one like times 10. um but they
said that people with narcissistic
personality disorder will not try to get
help
that's like the number one thing number
one there are a lot of people who who
have borderline or uh bipolar who are
really working on their issues who are
really trying to overcome and just kind
of like the trademark sign of
narcissistic personality disorder is
that they're like i don't you have the
problem how dare you say that that's
what my mom would do every single time
my grandpa my dad would beg my mom to
get help bake her to see a therapist say
you need to do something about this this
is destructive you can't do this to the
kids whatever their angle on the
argument was of the day she'd meet it
with you need help and she'd throw
something across the room and it'd be
violence and
um
and so yeah it's it's i'm i'm guessing
it was probably some combination of of
those and that's fascinating because
yeah the narcissism was looped into the
borderline that's like a
a double hweme a double mommy uh but i
also think you know can we if we can
just get a little bit granular on this
so narcissistic personality disorder
what's fascinating to me about it or
just doubly heartbreaking is that
narcissists have this reputation for
like well they think they're the best
and they
oh god they project that
and it is it comes from a
wildly deep profound insecurity and
self-hatred and they have to basically
project an identity that would be
acceptable usually to their primary
caretakers so what's so fucked up about
narcissism is that it's specific you
know so someone's like i'm the best at
football you know or like i'm the
prettiest person ever it's you can find
out what their parents would have
approved of based on what they project
around so it's if i'm the best football
player my dad will love me
right so it's like whatever their
specific narcissism is about is about
just trying to get love so
narcissist masquerade is the most
confident people on the planet but
it is because deep inside they feel like
they're absolutely nothing so it's this
tricky thing because they're such
fucking assholes yeah you know but
you're like oh this came from a wound
this came from something you didn't get
to
and then i think we should talk about
borderline personality disorder because
it is slightly different i think people
have a lot of questions about it it's
specific um
and uh
but that brings me to because you were
living with your grandparents too did
you see any like
from your grand your mother's mother
being able to go like well she got this
from you in some way were you able to
see how what your mom inherited yes from
your grandmother absolutely
from a very early age i
i just my grandma kind of rubbed me the
wrong way i felt like ooh this per i
don't like how she operates i don't like
whatever whatever world she's living in
doesn't seem like reality obviously i
couldn't put these thoughts i couldn't
form these thoughts but it was just a
really deep sense in me of like
that person you mentioned the sort of um
reading people or the gun instinct how
did you phrase it the discerning or i'm
forgetting the language around a
bullshit bullshit yeah
i feel like my grandma's bullshit was
just through the roof like i don't think
this person has any kind of ability to
be honest with herself or others that
generation though
yeah sure
would should they have sure sure
you know sure like this is what helps me
going into like the ancestral trauma of
okay
my grandmother grew up during this time
under these circumstances
why would
why wouldn't she live in complete denial
why wouldn't she be a complete robot of
uh self-delusion
and just complete pretending just to get
through life like what is her what did
she need to disassociate from what lies
did she need to tell herself to be able
to get through the day you know so i
wonder if i mean you mentioned that she
was
somewhat histrionic and would have big
mood swings so do you think she was
borderline also i i suspect that she was
also my and she's still alive she uh my
my grandfather
the thing about denial is like i i can
see that my grandfather lived in some
degree you know there are a lot of lies
that i think he told himself um there
are definitely a couple lenses of denial
around certain areas specifically um but
i but there was some sort of human
connection like
human humanity behind his eyes like i
didn't feel that from my
grandma really at all
um and and so i could kind of i i always
i didn't really feel sympathy for my
grandma even she would talk about kind
of her life and her woes and her
whatever i never really felt like oh my
heart goes out to grandma whereas with
my mom my heart
excessively went out to her um and i
think probably some of that was seeing
how my grandma treated her and be living
in the same household where i'm privy to
this dynamic on a daily basis and saying
that can't be easy
living with that
situation that's so wild because when
you're living with your mother and your
grandmother you're seeing that your
mother is also a child your mom's the
child of her
you know so there's like well we're in
this together you know that's a really
fascinating um uh thing to think about
because i found when i started putting
the pieces together of my the abuse in
my childhood i was so much more mad at
the people that knew about it and didn't
do anything than the actual abusers
because the abusers you're like well
they're sick that's a sick person they
obviously couldn't control their
behavior this person obviously you know
has a mental illness but all the people
standing around that knew about it they
didn't do anything about it y'all are
the ones that are you know ostensibly
saying why didn't you do something good
that's even crazier to me
to be the one that's not a criminal or
to be the one that doesn't have this
illness and to just
be in denial about it yeah yeah you know
so i found myself having to
grapple with my anger towards all the
people that did nothing
god
which was even a weirder thing because i
had stockholm syndrome with the abusers
you know i forgave them you know in a
way number one because they gaslet me
into believing that everyone else was
the enemy but still there's just so many
people to be mad at oh my god you know
yeah that it's hard to sort of parse out
and it seems like you have really
been able to um
neutralize the charge on everyone in
terms of like forgiveness on some level
uh i hope so um and maybe and more so on
some days than others for sure
can you kind of walk through like what
your process has been to
to get to where you are like was it was
it different kinds of therapy was it
you mentioned sort of codependency
programs or or al-anon was where did
like what was the starting place i guess
and then how to get to here gosh i'm
supposed to be asking you this
how dare you how dare you turn this i
would love to know truly i'm i'm always
curious about kind of people's history
with this and i'm going to answer your
question um i promise after we address
like two more things so then because
i've gone through a lot of the same
things so that way when we get to them
i'll walk through that because i also
just want to read this is the internet
definition of narcissistic personality
disorder one of several types of
personality disorder it is a mental
condition which people have an inflated
sense of their own importance a deep
need for excessive attention and
admiration
instagram troubled relationships and a
lack of empathy for others but behind
this mask of extreme confidence lies a
fragile self-esteem that's vulnerable to
the slightest criticism um so i remember
going to my therapist i mean like am i a
narcissist like doing what we do for a
living sometimes it's
hard to tell uh you're just like posting
about yourself and posting it and you're
like am i a narcissist like i feel like
all i think about is myself some you
know and um my therapist always like
narcissists don't schedule appointments
to go to therapy
and ask if they're narcissists but if
they do
because i've dealt with a narcissistic
person in my life in the past also and
sometimes they will use having gone to
therapy is like we'll see i know i did
this i did this for you
and also it didn't help in the therapist
that i didn't need to be there and i
passed
i know something i don't have that
experience with with somebody close to
them where they went to one therapy
session and then continued using it
we're like well i guess you need it
because they said i was great yeah i'm
fine i'm like oh cool therapist
said that to you all right
um and then borderline is something that
i think is worth talking about because
it's it's recently kind of in the
zeitgeist in in a way that's very
exciting but it's also i see people
misunderstanding it and uh
having grown up with a lot of it in my
life borderline personality disorder is
a mental illness that severely impacts a
person's ability to regulate their
emotions this loss of emotional control
can increase impulsivity affect how a
person feels about themselves and
negatively impact their relationships
with others so growing up with
borderline personality story is
terrifying um because you never know
where you stand and you never know what
the next second is gonna hold it's it's
someone that is very mercurial you never
know what's gonna set them off you can't
get a handle on how to please them and
how to consistently please them and
avoid
lashing outs and sometimes the more you
ostensibly like love them the worse it
gets um
i just call it getting in the cage with
a tiger you know it's just that said
this person's a tiger don't be in the
cage with them you know but you can
never really protect predict their moods
um the trick about borderlines is number
one it comes from a trauma and number
two
they feel it it's not a lie
they it's not a lie
oh yeah they're not manipulating you
they're not exaggerating they're not
they actually they're having an
appropriate response to whatever
stimulus has in their mind yeah so they
have a problem regulating their emotions
and
so if i'm borderline and i drop this and
it's like your fucking book if you
hadn't made it so slippery i wouldn't
have dropped it yes or whatever thing i
need to blame you for but
i have a wrong sized reaction like we
say and you know an allen i have to work
about right-sized reactions because we
watched people have such histrionic
reaction to such small things yes you
know because there was such a small
amount of self-care
that everyone was always at their
boiling point
oh my god you know so when someone is
always at their boiling point they're
not taking care of themselves with time
management with their you know mountain
health stuff like that and then
everybody else has to pay the price this
makes me think you know i certainly
can't i'm not able to diagnose my my
grandma but i'm gonna try to anyway
my my mom like i always felt
that her her reaction like her reaction
in some way made sense to me knowing
what i knew of her having organized her
the way that i did in my mind or the way
that i needed to as a kid i was like
okay
her having like it it did feel authentic
to me
the extremeness did feel sincere it
didn't feel like she was putting on some
performance unless it was to call a bill
collector which i was like oh but i also
understand that performance because
mom's trying to save us money like
everything kind of made sense was with
my grandma her
behaviors her intensity did seem a bit
performative it did seem it didn't seem
like it had that same authenticity
behind it um so it's interesting because
it's like it seems like your your
grandmother didn't have a lot to give or
didn't have a um
what that is fair to say so then it's
like on some level the child has to
be extra emotional extra uh loud in
order to get the attention of that
person
you know so it's kind of tricky like god
when that when you're trying to get
water from a stone
you have to
you know try so much harder in order to
get the attention in order to get the
love you need in order to get the care
you need you had to be dramatic you know
like so when you grow up in environments
where it's like i you know i hurt my
knee you're fine you're fine no one you
know you'd think i heard about
you such a histronic reaction in order
to get attention
i.e your brain
survival oh
yeah you know so your mom could have got
that honestly yeah yeah yeah which is
really hard to process
yes and i think that for me like as hard
as it is to forgive people that did like
incorrigible stuff
this this is just the way that i get out
of just like we forgive others not
because they deserve forgiveness but
because we deserve peace
you know and so that's
that's my current kink
like that's my new addiction it's just
like forgiving people just because it
feels better to me i've never been
good at forgiveness it's always kind of
i feel like i was in therapy for a long
time to find forgiveness for my mom like
even my intention and therapy was
certainly to get better and to not be
self-destructive but also in some way to
find that forgiveness for my mom it was
that was like the golden egg at the end
of the the rainbow
that's not that's like several fairy
tales make this
the pot of gold
sounds like a fertility crack
[Laughter]
i can see it like a rainbow and just a
bunch of eggs and like a cauldron at the
end it's for leprechauns
[Laughter]
oh boy but not that anyone deserves our
forgiveness necessarily we just deserve
it you know and i think i will say one
thing yes which is that
my sexual abuse as a child was uh from a
man and that is a little bit easier to
forgive in some way maybe for me because
my brain is like oh well
you're wired for that sick thing or you
know what i mean like you're
you
you don't know better
like or whatever i needed to hack my
brain in order to forgive mm-hmm do you
know what i'm saying
like you don't know better yeah you were
programmed to do this or there's some
you know
god
not that that's a reason to forgive
someone for doing that sure in general
but when i look back
if i would probably struggle more had it
been a woman you know my therapist said
to me at some point i i remember just
sort of like
saying i when will i get there like when
will i get to the place of forgiveness
why is this
so difficult for me to come to why why
is there still
anger years afterward like what's my
problem was kind of my the thing that i
took my therapist and she goes what if
you're not trying to forgive what if
that's just not the goal what if you
just let that go
and you stop doing your mom's work
because in a way this is you still doing
her work
mind-blowing
you know tears were shed and it felt
really freeing for me to hear that i
feel like it was what i what i needed to
hear because i was still trying to chase
that um
and now i you know i don't i don't know
i don't wouldn't even you maybe forgives
one of those words that i don't use like
might forgive my happy you know but um
like at peace with yeah or just this
person no longer has control over
i've worked through all the anger from
you know like i had to be so angry for
so
long oh my god once i
i think it was after my dad died you
know i needed
something really ex another extreme
emotional thing to happen um
that gave me that extra push to forgive
and maybe it was just a different kind
of pain and a different kind of anger so
i was like distracted like oh now this
hurts more
interesting so let me forgive this
person so i'm only suffering from one
thing so you're saying with your dad is
what that maybe led to some softening i
think it kind of just eclipsed the anger
towards what happened when i was a child
because it was just like oh
i kind of don't have the space to even
be mad about that anymore because i'm so
sad and angry about this
you know so the good news
is that soon something else bad will
happen it's interesting and then you'll
just it'll just move on to the next cia
compound great news
so it's like i think for me it was like
another catastrophic sort of
pain made me go like oh and then the way
that you know as you get older and you
kind of uncover parental like
systems like of their what they when you
have to when one of them pass away and
you have to deal with their accounts and
go another and you see like oh this
person was
so deeply unwell it was like you know
after my dad passed like going through
his financials i was just like oh my god
yeah yeah yeah yeah i can't even be mad
at this person because like just all of
everything that i discovered about the
way this person's life was
it's unruly i'm dealing with someone
that did not have the tools
like the fact that i'm alive is a
miracle yeah this person did a great job
given the tools they had
that doesn't mean they did a great job
had they had all the best tools but
given the tools they had so i think for
me it's not about was this a good was my
mom good or bad was my dad good or bad
did they do the best they could with the
tools they had good enough parenting my
therapist talks about that all the time
good enough parenting good enough it was
good enough you know huh kept you alive
what is that term that terms makes me
angry i know
like no it's never a good enough person
that to hear that it's just like no it's
good enough i'm like fuck yeah well it's
not in a way it's not in the sense of
like oh it's good enough like you like
you should be happy because it was good
yeah yeah yeah like no with the tools
that this person had with the place in
their life that they were in
it was good it was the best that they
could offer and it was thankfully good
enough and also at the time a complete
dearth of knowledge about mental health
i mean we didn't even know about
neuroscience i mean there's still we
don't even know a time about how the
brain works you know so it's like
you know you look back at just sort of i
mean my parents smoked in the car with
the windows up i mean it's just like on
this you know but
in terms of the active like abuse that
happened i'm curious if you know are you
able to
like
can we talk about ocd yeah
um are you ever at a point now in your
ocd recovery or dealing with it where
you're like oh this is where it's
benefiting me i don't want to do that
anymore but this benefit like in writing
a book where you're like oh i'm kind of
glad i have ocd i'm really
nailing it
like i was reading it i was like this
book is so good don't get rid of all
your ocd
i did feel it so i i was um i think i
had like six drafts that i could send in
to the label on on deadlines but i would
do like two drafts in between each draft
that i had to send them i think that was
ocd uh more so than i think i think the
ocd draws me to like really i mean even
with like the copy edit i don't i they
my copy editor might not be my biggest
fan my editor and i it was great but my
copy editor i'd be like the cadence no i
don't want a comma there because the
cadence needs to read this way and if
you have a comma i know that i read the
comma when i'm reading the thing and
then i'll pause when i can't pause
because it needs to have the rhythm and
then like every single thing that every
period is perfect
i mean perfect i told you i la i like
but this is
only an attention to detail and
punctuation like people understand this
the nurse tells me i can leave my shoes
on mom tells me to take them off always
look it out like that made me laugh out
loud but it was like that had to be a
period and then always looking out had
to be an exclamation mark
exactly you're right you're correct
thank you um but but yeah so there there
were some some some some back and forth
there was a bit of back and forth about
like well this isn't a proper like
grammatical punctuation marking and i'd
like but it's intentional it doesn't
work
it just has to feel right exactly it has
to feel where it has to read write has
to i really am a big fan of like the
rhythm and cadence i think that's ocd um
i have had a little bit of a flare uh
the past few weeks with like some
ritualistic behavior and like uh
very honestly like not being able to get
rid of a few things and i'm like oh god
this can't like this i'm not is it like
an item
as in like i finished a fresh
moisturizer uh glossier brand like
moisturizer i was using as a hand cream
i finished it and i'm like oh but i
can't get rid of the
bottle because take it
i'll take it i mean it could be refilled
it could be recycled or like what if we
could just continue
like also like there might be some left
in there
yeah like i'm just saying like did you
totally roll it like did you get all of
it out of there because you could also
cut it because there could be more in
there
and also like what if you forget the
name of it or the like you would have to
keep it and a picture is not gonna be
enough yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
it's like i'm gonna sort through to find
that totally i do put in your favorites
yeah so it's a whole but that but just
there's so but what if like you need to
show it to someone i don't know there's
a
lot
i'm um glad question mark intentional
question mark that you can relate yes
but i've got a so uh it's funny because
um
nicole amy schreiber comedian who also
helped me you know like organize the
house uh she'd be like like hoarding
just because you have a like space
like
i've decided it's collecting like when
is it not hoarding in a collection just
like just because it's on a shelf
doesn't mean it's not hoarding
like that's so funny because i also have
ocd which is just fun we're just all
three of us what are the odds um
but uh my one of my roommates in college
gave me an orange right before like
during finals week like right before uh
the end of the semester and i didn't eat
it and it was in my backpack and then
when i got home for the semester i
realized that i still had it
and i was right before i was studying
abroad i took the orange with me to
europe
kept it in my backpack the entire time
walked it around like all over europe
brought it home with me had it until i
graduated from college a year later and
my mom was cleaning out my room and she
was like why do you still have this wait
this is a dried out orange like a
tangerine pumpkin yeah it's probably
but i was like if i get rid of it like
meg will either die or she'll hate me
right
that doesn't make sense but if you on
the off chance you are a witch
listen blood on her hands i could be
right that's the problem like it sounds
good like that's the problem if you give
you know it's vile if you keep it long
enough she will die that's true
it's a self-fulfilling prophecy so
that's i mean when it comes to like the
hoarding and ocd and all that stuff i
think the key is for me has been to be
gentle with myself and go why does this
give me so much comfort
having to navigate
of when is this hoarding when is this
ocd and when is this me making myself
happy in self-care yeah it's when it
stops being a choice yeah so if i'm on
etsy at two in the morning and i cannot
stop ordering stuff
we have a problem um but if i can go oh
my god i really want this
you know worm from the labyrinth or
whatever and
you know what
i'm gonna heart it and i'm gonna come
back in a couple days yeah and see i
just have to be able to
um live without it and i just have to be
able to not
go to external things to meet internal
needs like if i throw this away will i
fall apart emotionally
if that's the case we have a big problem
yeah am i
using external things for internal to
meet an internal need i like that yeah
trying to use external things to meet an
internal need so happiness which we
don't you know don't love the word but
happiness is an inside job am i trying
to get an inside job done with external
things alcohol drugs sex
work
stuff you know um but i think it's good
to because it is a form of self-care to
know what makes you happy yeah or what
you enjoy and to have the stuff around
yes so what's the thing you didn't want
to throw away uh oh the hand cream yeah
glossier hand cream and what was the
thought the thought process was
uh i wasn't really concerned about them
not having anymore i was like oh
think things are going well right now
yes and i'm worried that things won't go
well if i get rid of this hand cream
container
if i change one thing yeah yeah this is
going to be the thing that tips it i
have the same thing like really yo yeah
like i like i'll buy nice journals
because i like to journal and i like to
write but then i'll write a couple pages
and then something really good will
happen and i'll be like
i have to keep it i can't write it
anymore yes
this is the thing let me ask a question
is there a biological basis for ocd as
in was that ever true
so sometimes things that you know don't
work well in current times you know
hypervigilance hypersensitivity
uh all the stuff that women are
pathologized to do as uh in today's
culture yes of course it seems hyper
vigilant but what was that what was that
what was that because we have locks on
our doors we have you know door guys in
apartments we have alarm systems
whatever but that worked really well on
the range
in the jungle in tribal times you were
the most important person in the tribe
the more hypervigilant the more anxious
you were so people now who are like i
have an anxiety of crippling anxiety
crippling anxiety a thousand years ago
saved the lives of everyone of the tribe
because you're like i think that's line
is that it's definitely lion you're
crazy it's a lion yeah and then you save
the tribe so now it's just there's no
lions and whatever
so ocd
you know
in tribal times the person that couldn't
stop picking the berries was probably
the most valuable gatherer right the
person who was like i am not going to
stop until i get this dear the person
that was the most quote-unquote ocd
about getting the d whatever yeah is you
know was the hero so
ocd in terms of i wonder if there was a
biological basis for if i change this
one thing everything's gonna fall apart
i'm sure that was
just science a thousand years ago that
was just real science it was like okay
i did this and this and this and it
rained if you move that thing the house
is going to fall apart
yeah yeah you know and so i better not
do that again or i better do that again
because last time i did that behavior it
rained yeah and we got crops or last
time we did that you know there was more
bunnies to i don't know
i'll keep the hand cream jar right i
keep it
what i'm saying is your therapist is
wrong
and so but that helps me forgive my that
process studying um you know neurology
biological basis for a lot of these
behaviors has helped me have compassion
for myself yeah and not over pathologize
them like i'm so crazy it's like no i
was just born
a thousand years ago i would have the
most valuable person in the tribe i
would have saved everybody's life with
these thoughts in this behavior
that society has changed so fast that a
lot of these tools are just obsolete and
we just need to sort of reroute these
superpowers i love that and i need that
i'm i'm constantly in a state of i wish
therapy could just wrap up i wish i
could just be like okay i'm i don't need
this anymore i'm complete i'm done i'm
like i'm solved but um but kind of
acknowledging i don't know just that
it's ongoing and
and the the not pathologizing i like
that a lot yeah just like finding ways
to have compassion for things that you
know
are ostensibly like weaknesses yeah or
wounds you know it's like it's not being
in denial of trauma you know but i think
it's just like the next level of okay
like how do we
like
fuck with ourselves yeah in a good way
like how are we just like
i think that's the next level i fuck
with myself because i do that you know
what i mean like that's sick that i do
that like i have this thing i just have
to know why i'm doing it and i just have
to be doing it for the right reasons and
it has to stay a choice yes
taking another little break sometimes i
think i stutter and i don't yeah isn't
that kind of weird yeah it's a verbal
dysmorphia yeah jeremy i think it
sounded worse than it did right you know
so um that's cool no solution for that
but
we don't have a product to solve that
but
i am very excited because there is
finally a company that um gets me it is
called newly newly is a monthly clothing
subscription service we finally found a
place that sells my style aka
child from stranger things
in a subscription clothing service 88 a
month you get your choice of any six
styles you don't only have to dress like
a child from stranger things you can
dress however you want but this place
actually has right vintage every
different horse girl anything you want
you name it with newly you can get your
choice of any six styles each month you
choose whatever you want to rent for
whatever you have going on it's totally
up to you your body your choice oh well
just kidding access to thousands of
styles for more than 300 brands
everything from party dresses to premium
denim and one-of-a-kind vintage pieces
newly stocked styles in a range of sizes
from petite to plus sizes up to five
plus
plus maternity they carry labels like
for love and lemons love shaq fancy lisa
lisa says god this is sorry i thought
that was saying lisa i obsessed that
it's called that yeah fast free shipping
and returns and professional cleaning in
newly state of the art laundering
facility no laundry for you to worry
about the option to buy what you love at
a discount sometimes up to 70 off newly
has everything you need to bring your
closet up to speed for this season stock
up on a new dress for every event
without breaking the bank say yes to all
the current trends y2k throwbacks sets
check or print crochet without feeling
the fast fashion
get all the fashion you need while you
need it then let newly worry about where
it gets stored fall through spring dream
closet unlock newly is flexible there
are no fees late fees damage fees or
fees to pause or cancel so no big deal
if you lose a button spill something or
just need to take a break your life
needs to flex and newly gets it i mean
with these cute tops people can be
ripping them off and the buttons are
going to go flying not your problem
newly lets you love fashion in a way
that's kinder on the planet orders are
shipped in recycled recyclable and
reusable totes with no plastic packaging
using energy and water efficient methods
and most importantly styles are repaired
and upcycled rather than thrown out
wearing and re-wearing clothing as much
as possible is one of the most
sustainable choices you can make and
that's newly specialty newly is already
a great value at 88 a month for any six
styles but right now you can get 10 off
your first month of newly when you sign
up with the code whitney10 just go to
n-u-u-l-y dot com that's newly with two
u's and enter the code whitney10 and
sign up to get ten dollars off your
first month maybe just don't try and go
get the vest from the 80s for
little boy toddlers cause we already got
all those that's
n-u-u-l-y.com newly with 2us with
codewhitney10.
gosh is my shit newly subscription
clothing rental change your clothes
change your clothes what a great tagline
yeah that is a good tagline
i bet you can get fun like vintage
football team shirts on newly and you
can
you said i bet you can get
oh that's even better
football fans here we are
first sunday of the nfl season is
here it's here draftkings sportsbook an
official sports betting partner of the
nfl is giving
new customers a can't miss offer to
celebrate the return of the nfl season
don't just
take risks with the people you're dating
and the sushi you eat from the grocery
store it's actually fun to do with
sports it's the best way to bet because
you actually have a little bit of data
but then it's a little bit of how much
you know about it's a little bit about
your gut i am now obsessed with football
after uh watching it with giannis pappas
uh he made me like understand how to
like enjoy it and i mean watching other
men like
suffer because their team is losing is
part of the joy for i just yeah it's so
fun to watch everyone just get so
emotional about it you're not on the
team
as an added bonus for week one everyone
can experience the thrill of draftkings
early win promotion it's simple bet on
an nfl team to win your team leads by 10
at any point during the game you get
paid instantly even if your team loses
what is our team now the team from
washington no are the commanders
what that's the dc team ah
c-u-m
we're still keeping it old school with
the kansas city chiefs
we are
just download the draftkings sportsbook
app now and use promo code whitney to
get 200 in free bets instantly when you
place a 5
bet this sunday that's code whitney only
at draftkings sportsbook an official
sports betting partner of the nfl
minimum age and eligibility restrictions
apply see show notes for details
back to the show
can we talk about um so the eating stuff
so or how do you like to say that
i say eating disorders i know there's
some talk about why we should say
disordered eating but i don't really
understand i think eating disorders is
the simplest way it seems like people
that don't struggle with this like to
come up with words of how we should talk
about it yeah they're like let's say
disordered meaning okay thank you like
fucking nerd because that's the other
thing when people get too into that it's
also a control addiction so when people
like i call it disordered eating i'm
like okay that's part of your control
thing i'll
do you feel like um
uh
this new
like it's not new this like body
positivity
thing
i find it
annoying
uh because it's just at the end of the
day just focusing on people's weight
regardless yeah and i feel like i've
worked so hard on my eating disorder
recovery and i'm like at this place
where it doesn't run my life yes and
then this ubiquitous
anyone can be any size and i'm not
saying it's not true or false i
it is what it is but this new obsession
with bodies at every weight yeah is
almost
is
getting me and i think it's
because of that eating disorder ghost
that's in there hmm i a friend of mine
told me
i
expressed something similar to her this
is a couple years back and she goes have
you heard of body neutrality
and i guess that's
the direction that things are going and
i'm like at a certain point what is it
are we just slapping a new word on the
same thing are we just like oh let's
find a different angle on this so that
that one's not old you know let's let's
update this um
and yeah my question is sort of is body
neutrality body positivity 2.0 or is
there some value to it um because i i
there's something that felt a bit even
phony about body positivity because i
felt like okay they're still they're
still selling things off of being like
i'm such a good corporation that i am
showing somebody with
one little stretch mark on their leg
like look at me go and it's still like
there's such a kind of it just feels
false to me i don't know in my opinion
it feels like just capitalism and
everyone's falling for it it's like
yeah the fact that these brands that
only had models that were size zero five
years ago now that they have sixes and
eights were like oh my god
you are so brave you know it's just this
just new obsession with women's weight
in a different direction yeah that is
still an obsession with weight i agree i
agree and it also feels like a false
fake solve to a problem that clearly
people don't understand if they think
that this is progress because so much of
disordered eating body dysmorphia etc
has nothing to do with magazines has
nothing to do with the images we see oh
thank you for saying that i feel like
there's so much of like blaming society
on these things for me it was about
control it was about staying young and
youthful it was about fulfilling my
mom's wants for me it was so much more
specific there was no way it could have
just been
assigned to society's doing that's why
like i wasn't even privy to society i
was in a fucking room with my mom all
the time like i didn't go anywhere what
did they mean society i don't know i
think that's such an easy i think that's
such low-hanging fruit because society
is to blame for everything yeah i think
it's also a also just like a lack of
education lack of understanding of like
you know usually what i had eating
disorders before i had ever read a vogue
magazine before i had seen beverly hills
902 now like it didn't even it wasn't
about
looking like the society standard of
beauty it was about getting attention
disappearing and people worrying about
me you know and about control like so
it had nothing to do with that i think
it's an easy thing to blame and it's
just a lack of understanding also
there was you know to me when
now i feel like i have to rush but also
i want to ask you because it's gonna um
these will fork i promise which is did
you feel like before you had an
understanding of your the abuse as a
child before you had the understanding
around that
the when the denial started to break you
know after lauren after you saw the
therapist lauren and then moved on you
know to jeff i believe
did you feel like oh that's why i do all
those things in terms of when you were
able to put it together about the sexual
abuse because i had a therapist explain
to me that i was sexually abused and i
was like no i'm not like i didn't even
underst like and
there were cues that i didn't even know
that were effects from that for example
she asked me what i sleep in and i sleep
in like a full suit like annie hall
pants
like button up like bla ty
monocle
top hat paint like i'm in a full
yes totally so i would always sleep you
know fully clothed and i just i didn't
hoodie like i never put together that
that is often something that happens if
you were abused sexually abused as a
child you know as a way to have you know
layers on as a way you know i'm starving
yourself also a way to have control
because you don't have control over your
body i think on some level it was also
to make yourself i did to make myself
less sexual and to make myself like look
sick yes and not have curves or not be
womanly but
obviously people that abuse children
don't right want them to look like women
right that's the whole point right you
know so things like that um so and then
a lot of i always get very defensive of
people when um they attack uh women that
have like a bunch of a ton of plastic
surgery you know because a lot of times
that is a maladaptive behavior from the
trauma being sexually abused you want to
change the person that got molested you
want to look in the mirror and see a
different person
kind of thing so
were there any things that you
didn't really necessarily like pick up
on and went oh that's why i do that
thing
um so much
clothing is really what came to mind
first there was such a weird
relationship complicated relationship
with clothing and understanding that um
and not and i would dress to not be
sexualized and then
um would dress to conceal certain parts
of my body like there was so much there
was so much math to what i wore every
day it was trying to work around my
insecurities instead of just like oh you
know now i'm so happy that it can just
be i'm so
some version i'm so joyful you can use
that if it works for you i don't mean to
take that word for it it's over for
everyone for me i guess i just like the
idea of happy just felt so much pressure
like i have to be like yes you know the
scientologist running through a meadow
like i'm like
you know so and usually when i'm happy
people like what's wrong and i'm like
i'm happy it's just my voice and my face
interesting but now i'm i'm i'm thrilled
to be able to wear stuff that i like and
just say oh i
i thought that looked so great when i
saw it and i picked it out and now i
wear it and that
it's so simple and i'm glad that i hope
most people operate that way but i
really didn't and it was really really
such a complicated
um
thing for me and then of course there
were a million food rules and and
exercise roles and there was just i mean
it was it was an array of chaos um but
the the clothing thing was like a more
fun element that came together later
like oh i didn't even realize that i was
doing that avoiding avoiding situations
um oh i'm not going to go out to eat
with this person i'm not going to be in
any sort of social setting because i
work because there's like endless food
at social settings and it's just like
piles of thing and i don't want to do
that um
just uh you know avoiding rooms yeah was
there um for me there was a giant link
between my fear of women and friendships
uh certainly female friendships
because you can't get as much past women
you know what i mean like they know uh
so number one you can't go to dinner
with a woman and pull off and eating of
the like right you know what i'm gonna
have the burger or the pasta uh you know
i'll just i'll get the salad dressing on
the side
like you can't
you know what i mean that's the main
move is i'm gonna deliberate between the
fettuccine alfredo and the spaghetti
bolognese and then when the waiter comes
i'm gonna pretend i'm overwhelmed and
can't make a decision
and i'm pretending those were actually
real
options you know what fine i'll just get
the steamed broccoli with no better
thanks that's fine whatever
um you know when i'd eaten four cinnamon
fucking cinnabons in the car and like
puked them up in lake hollywood so
i mean i have i don't so i wrote a book
and um
it came out the day of the vegas
shooting so didn't get to do a ton of
press i don't know why people didn't
want to hear about like me and my eating
disorder after 50 people have been
slaughtered in vegas but um
i uh
the eating disorders are so insidious
that you know this is why an allen on
alcoholism you know eating disorders
today it's the disease that tells you
you don't have a disease you know it's
like the disease of perception the
disease of
this is the last time i'm gonna do it
and you say that for six years and you
mean it every time that's the crazy part
you mean it yeah and no one wants to be
an alcoholic no one wants to be a no one
wants to be borderline no one wants to
have any you know so for me anorexia i
shined so bright with my anorexia
and the drinking diet cokes all day and
then sugar-free candy my big thing was
debilitating myself with protein bars
the so much sugar-free candy sugar-free
twizzlers that i like had to be in fetal
position and then i could incapacitate
myself so that i could isolate and not
have to be around people because food is
so social you can't socialize without
some kind of and then like you mentioned
your book i related so deeply of like
the
multitasking of eating and talking to
someone because you have to do all the
math of what you're eating and how much
you're eating and yeah am i selling this
and how much are they eating whatever
um and uh
and then the just oh my god so
embarrassing what this happened
next to quentin tarantino one time
the bulimia for me
which i didn't really identify as
bleeding until like i was really able to
go oh yeah i used to just like puke
behind cars
in a way that i didn't even know i was
doing it it was that fast
so it's like i would binge on stuff that
was really easy to throw up that's what
i would pick so it was like protein
powders that would mix it always is
right you know the stuff that's going to
come up quickest most easiest yeah and
so i would get these protein powders and
like swiss miss and
just like whatever chemically flavory
sugar-free etc and then mix it in like
water
eat it like pudding
and then i would go for a walk around
the neighborhood it's like
and i but i didn't even really
understand that i was doing it that i
was i never identified as bulimic i was
like oh no that just didn't
yes take yes because i eat i wasn't
doing it over a toilet yeah it was like
just around secretly yeah i hid it from
myself yeah yeah yeah does that even
make sense it totally unfortunately it
completely does and i feel like that's
because bulimia for me was so much more
it was so much less admirable than
anorexia my i i don't believe anybody's
ever aiming for bulimia i believe the
aim is always anorexia and bulimia is
what you experience if you like can't do
anorexia that's my my interpretation of
it so i feel like anything that could
like i would say bulimia took me a long
time to identify as well in myself as
like oh this is actually what's
happening i would kind of like i knew i
was throwing up and doing the binging
and purging but i could just kind of say
like well but it's temporary or like
well because mom died like i could find
these justifications that somehow like
but you're still doing the thing like
what are you talking about no well but i
could stop whenever like i really could
get a handle on it i need something
really unhealthy and throw it up and be
like well it was like that would have
been so bad for me
oh my god if i ate that like i'm just
like taking care of myself that's just
completely sound logic had i actually
digested that you know how bad that
would have been for me yeah yeah i'm
doing myself a favor self-care yeah and
so it's also like you know the irony of
it being a control addiction and
whatever you try to control ends up
controlling you what would you say to
someone
who
has someone in their life struggling
with this
in terms of how to behave because i feel
like
everyone's got someone in their life who
i think has probably got some
[Music]
thing and i always say you got to leave
them alone
there's nothing you can you just got to
let them
you know
i i do think it has to come from i was
approached by by my boyfriend at the
time and then also by my sister-in-law
saying like you need to get help like
this is an issue you need to do
something about this um and
on the one hand i was grateful on the
one hand it led me to start trying
therapy and dipping my toe in the water
of like okay let me see if i can work on
this but then i eventually quit and i i
need i needed to come to it on my own
but i do appreciate that they confronted
me about it i think that's a really hard
thing to do it's something i have
struggled with a lot of just confronting
somebody with something that i feel
strongly and i think it's cool that they
did that so i'm almost inclined to say
try to approach or if you don't
understand it yeah just give them your
book
give them give them just give them
access to wisdom send them a podcast
something like hey i'm worried about
your eating if you know nothing about it
it's like
just send them to someone that does yeah
and i do hope kind of bringing it back
to your point about triumph uh
i i hope that we can get to a place
where it is that's the piece that's like
romanticized as opposed to like
romanticizing the
the
the uh mental illness of it all like i
do i do think there's a bit of
romanticizing happening around like oh
depression or anxiety you're like
and it's like i think i think there's
hope to if if the romanticizing is on
the triumphing over it well because i
also see this new like wellness
thing as just one giant eating disorder
so it's like and now i'm intermittent
fasting and now i don't eat gluten and i
only eat maple syrup three times a week
and then i eat clay and drink charcoal
i'm like guys yep guys count my macros
do my guys
yeah yeah
those who don't know
tell me seven's like intermittent
fasting is the best thing for you i'm
like bitch i did that people said 20
years they told us that counting
calories was bad yeah they were like but
what if you didn't eat for two days
like it just sounds good for you
these new i mean on one hand i'm kind of
like
you know slightly tickled that men now
have eating disorders
you know it's like i see these men that
are like i only i eat this protein bar
and then i do the ice bath and then i
you know eat once a day and i only eat
you know celery and jalapenos and i'm
now in ketosis i'm like hey dude
whatever you need to call it
whatever you need to call it but
i'm i feel grateful that i'm at a place
where i don't have like judgment about
it because i'm like i know all the ways
that i
sold my eating disorders as allergies as
now i'm vegan i'm vegetarian i'm
pescatarian now i'm this now i don't
need things with faces like i still you
know have my
things that you know my boundaries
around food obviously but
you know do you sometimes see that and
go like i know what that is i
had a uh an instinct to suddenly go
vegan in my recovery and my therapist
had suggested that i not do that that i
have zero food rules um for at least two
years and i have been
i consider myself recovered for
way significantly longer than two years
at least five years now i want to say um
but i don't have any food rules and i'm
open to at some point if i wanted to try
to be a vegetarian or pescatarian or
something i'm open to that but i'd have
to be really really
really double triple quadruple check
myself on it but right now i have no
food rules i love all food like i'm such
a foodie i do feel like that's the case
with most people who have experienced
eating disorders i love um
i love food and i'm glad i don't have
any rules around it i don't want to be i
don't want to be enslaved to it the way
i was before
um
what is
next
what do you want to do next
i'm working on a novel and a collection
of essays and i've been working on this
for a couple months and really um
enjoying those i'd also i'd love to do
more directing something like in a set
environment with
um with people around me it's a lot of
like me in a room typing these days um
but i i'm excited about both of us
and can i just
i have so much i want to ask i feel like
i'm not allowed to ask anymore can i
just say i'm annoyed
i'm annoyed i'm gonna be honest i
thought we were gonna have more time i'm
sorry but this is exactly the interview
it should have been i have to be in my
third step um could i just as someone
that has spent so much time examining
themselves understanding the motives of
others etc etc protecting yourself um
what would you say are some red flags in
people
not that there's anything wrong with
them we don't have to judge but we do
get to take cues from people when they
tell us who they are and then we get to
protect ourselves
a big one for me is if you set a
boundary if i try to set a boundary and
a person i totally get having a reaction
to a boundary i understand that i
understand wanting to be close to
someone i understand being hurt if
somebody sets a boundary i get all of it
but if somebody doesn't uh take
accountability for their reaction to the
boundary or doesn't like really express
hey it this really hurts me but totally
i get it or have some sort of honest
accountability on in their lane and they
just push back on the boundary
repeatedly they gotta go yes gotta go
and there are a couple choices though
there are choices in the way you set
boundaries so it's like when we're
setting them we try to make sure that we
say what we mean mean what we say don't
say it mean like you're fucking pissing
me off step back so that's not setting a
boundary that's just you know what i
mean which is such a learning curve i'm
glad you say that because it was really
hard for me initially because of the
extreme thinking i just be like i can't
talk to this person and i felt like
robotic when i tried to set a boundary i
could i felt like i couldn't be a human
because oh if i'm a human they'll know
how to twist and get what they want out
of me and i will suddenly become
helpless it was my fear so i'd get
overly cold overly clinical overly
robotic hand it on a platter and it's
like that's fucking weird no i wish i
don't do that it's not it's not it's
just that's you know your brain is just
trying to protect you that's all like
when we get emotional it's just our
brains trying to protect us that's all
based on the data it has so
there's boundaries are such a tricky one
because i hear this word a lot and i
think people are really experimenting
with it but i think people are not um
i had i didn't understand what boundary
meant when i first came to the program
which is boundaries are not for them
it's for us so number one before you set
a boundary you make sure that you're
actually willing to carry out the
consequence that you have already
planned for if this person does not
honor the boundary so we never set a
boundary until we're actually ready to
follow through with the consequence
because otherwise we are going to lose
respect for ourselves and our
self-esteem is going to degrade so if i
go jeanette if you do that again i'm
leaving yeah i better be ready to leave
before i say that so then i'm gonna set
this boundary so i better get my shit
together pack my bag get a hotel
and then set the boundary in case the
purse because the boundaries for myself
yeah it's i you can't expect someone you
have to set the boundary with to honor
the boundary because the fact that you
have to set the boundary in the first
place is all the information you need to
know so you have to be ready to actually
follow through with it because if i say
if you say that again i'm leaving and i
don't then you've lost respect for me
i've lost respect for myself and now
we're i'm just embarrassed
and you know and so there's that but
then also it's like not going to the
problem for the solution right so a lot
of times we're like you're my problem i
need you to solve the problem i have
with you
right so a lot of times it's okay every
time jeanette says this thing it really
pisses me off and i want to set this
boundary to say don't say that again but
then i might go to my therapist or my
program and go like every time um
jeanette says this it pisses me off and
then i might be like well why does it
piss you off all she's doing is saying
you look nice today and or she's just
saying she
you know thinks you're or whatever it is
maybe
you you're maybe you don't need to set
that boundary maybe you need to just get
more comfortable and flexible with
people being able to say xyz to you or
do x y or maybe you need to just remove
yourself maybe she's done nothing first
you have to make sure you're not
overreacting i love that i love being
history you know when we want to set a
boundary right we also might just need
to develop the
tolerance of being able to be
uncomfortable or being able to receive
love or being able to you know don't
hold my hand in public i need to set
this boundary it's like well what's
going on with me that this is
embarrassing that this makes me
uncomfortable and then once we've
cleaned our whole side of the street and
vetted all of our motives then we go you
know what yes i've gone through all the
other choices the the 100
thing i should do is set this boundary
and then we go and it's say what you
mean me what you say don't say it mean
and it can't be out of blame it can't be
like well you need to stop doing this
because when you do this i then do this
yeah yeah yeah so i need you to walk on
it because a lot of times when we're
quote setting boundaries we're actually
just making people walk on eggshells
around us right which is what
borderlines do
so it's like when we step back we really
have to make and then we go okay hey
um whatever your boundary you know is
could you please not use your phone
while we're at dinner yeah it just makes
me feel good you know and here's why and
we have to say what we mean when we say
don't say it mean that's important
because if we go can you not use your
phone at dinner that's not setting a
boundary that's starting a fight oh
yes but so yes so there's a difference
between standing up for yourself and
making other people walk on eggshells
and looking at the motive because as
someone that wants to control everyone
all the time
boundaries can be
a gateway drug
interesting
so if i want to set a boundary i have to
first figure out what's going on with me
and then be ready to carry out the
consequence and then um make sure it's
for the good of the relationship so
sometimes yes yes so boundaries are
going to make us healthier because
intimacy and proximity are not the same
thing oh my god yeah yeah yeah you know
yeah sometimes intimacy and proximity
just means you're entrenched that was
mind-blowing when i first when i first
heard that oh intimacy does because i
thought well boundary because my mom
conditioned me this way but it was like
oh a boundary means that i don't love a
person enough a boundary means that i
am not being fair to them or that i'm
hurting them no intimacy is cultivated
with appropriate boundaries
could not believe and if you cannot
comfortably set a boundary with someone
you don't have intimacy and if you need
to be with someone all the time because
you're worried they're going to cheat
abandon you change you know do something
that you're not going to understand grow
apart from you that is not intimacy you
know that is insecure attachment god and
that obsession and love addiction etc i
know your publicist is like perched on
the edge um i'm drawing a boundary with
him right now which is that you live
here now um
because i think that i think that this
is this is something that you know is
just wildly important because i think
there's this moment of like just draw
boundaries with everyone all the time
sometimes that can be controlling and
that can be you know so i think
also instead of going like hey i'm gonna
draw boundary which is like you know i'm
gonna tell her can you not post all this
and no i just need to unfollow you or
mute you what i'm saying first see what
you can do
to take care of yourself before you set
the boundary because sometimes we think
it's gonna it's like a it's a drug like
anything else if i just take this drink
everything will be okay if i just set
this boundary everything will be okay
and then you're in this whack-a-mole you
have like a house of cards of boundaries
that's right that's right you know and
and so i think a lot of people when they
think they're setting boundaries they're
just being control freaks and making
everyone else walk on eggshells around
them and it's your job to heal yourself
and this is something i am so impressed
i don't know you that well like i'm so
impressed by you i am so like proud of
you thank you i know i
the work you have done
is so relentlessly
um
fearless and and i and
i i don't know if people understand how
easy it could have been for you to just
do blow and become a billionaire on a
sitcom
and just
be a nightmare like you do you know what
i mean like you could have just done
that
you could just be
doing molly you could
have
you just really chose to do it the hard
way the gritty way and
the amount of integrity you have is
unbelievably impressive and grace thank
you so much oh my god because
there are a lot of people who also would
do this
and want to be superior
and want to be the best victim and want
to use it to control other people
and
um i see a lot of people that are just
i'm this is a judgment but i go like ugh
that's not a good ambassador
for
this
and not that you're a bad person but
this person like
has more work to do or if i had read
that when i was 20 it would have
confused me yes you know what i mean
because now it's like they're using this
for something that is
they there there's more clarity to be
had there yes and i just the fact that
you
um had some whatever darwinian self
preservation or just
wanted to do it the right way and go all
around the track
um and not take any shortcuts
there's nothing like that eating
disorder work dude it is the most gnarly
gritty
warrior shit there is
thank you for the for the kind words it
does it feels very
fulfilling to feel validated for
something that
you know the work behind you know that
you know the the years behind as opposed
to i i know what it feels like to be
validated for something like yeah that's
not why i don't think people understand
overcoming an addiction that you have to
participate in three times a day oh my
god you know every other addiction it's
like okay don't drink
i don't know how to be you can't be
fully abstinent cut it out right it's
like an alcoholic that has to do three
shots a day
right
it really i think yeah begs for the work
on the relationship with the thing in a
complicated way
do you celebrate yourself
um i do i just i i went to the grand
california hotel at disneyland i went to
the the it's their their like cabin
themed
hotel
and i want to celebrate i'm tr i'm
trying to uh i'm trying to
to do more of that
because like
it's a form of gratitude
and i'm finding like i tend to not
celebrate myself and uh i tend to not
acknowledge my accomplishments um so i'm
just curious if you do and where you are
on that yeah and just this whole sort of
process
why do you not or where do you
because either i don't find them
impressive or i didn't yeah i didn't
think they were
all i see is all the compromises i made
or
like you know
is there some is there one thing that
you've celebrated or something that
comes to mind it's like oh but i did
celebrate that or appreciate that in
myself in a deeper way
like what well i feel like when you
celebrate yourself it becomes you like
your thing with being in service to
others i feel like oftentimes when you
you are celebrating yourself but you do
it in a way that becomes service to
others like when you finally finished
your house
which is like it was this massive
undertaking this huge renovation like it
was a really big deal and it's something
that you'd wanted for a long time um and
then like to celebrate it you threw a
big christmas party for a bunch of other
people
nightmare
it was a nightmare but like that that
was you like wanting to invite other
people to like celebrate your house with
you and like celebrate this thing that
you would done for yourself yeah by like
inviting a bunch of people to get
absolutely trapped well that mice that
is also so um there's like you said
before there's and the pandemic was a
little bit of a curveball with kicking
up some things i didn't even know i even
had and i think that i
also
uh
over socialized to isolate because then
you don't have to talk to anyone in
depth or have any meaningful connections
with people it's like hi hi hi and it
gets to you know what i mean so i think
that's also a way that i can avoid
intimacy in a way is that just have so
either so many people around that i
don't have to
make eye contact with anyone and feel
that pressure because sometimes like
um
you know which also is a red flag if
someone's friendship feels like pressure
to you first do your side of the street
to see why but also i feel um now that
i'm able to
have an honest relationship about what i
require in order to feel full in order
to have my glass be full um because
that's a classic alan thing is we just
give away what we don't have you know we
deplete ourselves giving to other people
when you know we only the idea is you
only give when your glass is completely
full and um so i find myself now that i
know what i need other people if i feel
like they're the type of people that
don't get their own needs met internally
i feel pressure yeah yeah yeah yeah
cause like because and then my favorite
red flag is insecurity insecure people
are dangerous you know we tend to
conflate love and pity and i think that
especially as people that
are sort of on the other side of
recovery sometimes when i see in other
people i'm like what's the difference
between being of service of this person
and giving back to someone that was and
martyring myself on someone and
pitying someone you know pitying someone
never helps them yes it's not it's not
kind yes you know help is not so there's
that kind of thing but i think sometimes
it's just a matter of self-care stuff
and the hanging out my horse is my big
way to celebrate because i go oh i have
this new level of success or this new
thing which means there's circumstances
i'm not familiar with which means my uh
old software could easily pop up you
know i've upgraded my software to
whitney 2.0 but when things change or
there's new circumstances who knows what
coping mechanism what my brain is gonna
think as oh this is scary this is a
threat you need to resort to those old
coping mechanisms to cope with this
change
so that's when i'm the most vigilant
it's like when something good happens
that's when i need to be the most
vigilant about making sure that these
maladaptive behaviors don't pop up and
sabotage it all yeah so that's when i
lean and go like okay something good
happen i need to celebrate by going to a
meeting i need to celebrate by going to
do work with my horse to make sure that
i can handle this next level of pressure
stress
achievement
whatever
you know and last thing i'll say is um
since my dad died a couple years ago
i've also
had a hard time celebrating
you know it's it's it's hard to
celebrate i still feel a little bit of
like guilt or like what's the point or
like
i was doing this all for him anyway so
who's like who cares oh my god you know
it's just sort of like i have this
rudderless like purposelessness you know
so just the last thing is like now that
your mom is gone and you know what is
your driving
um
inspiration now that you've had to kind
of uh
build a new engine for yourself god i
love that phrasing and i also relate to
the feeling of i felt completely like
pointless and why who fucking cares
about anything why is this
what's the point none of this matters
like a real
emptiness you know for so long after
after she died
i would say my driving engine
so like i don't have a a deeper answer
than just what feels
the mo like i do a lot of gut checks on
does this feel like it needs to be
um
done through me does this feel like it
it's every part of me is kind of like
compelled to do this or does this feel
like i'm just like some doing something
to fill the time does it feel like and
whether that's a relationship or a um or
creative you know project i'm focusing
on or or a professional
opportunity
you know what this is such a corny
saying but i love the saying if it's not
a hell yes it's a no i love it right my
book yeah it's just absolutely it's so
good right yeah i think that was ryan
holiday i think hughes has said that
it's so it's so good it's not a hell yes
it's a no if it's a maybe i could
probably i could maybe convince myself
that it's no because as soon as you
start talking yourself into something
rationalizing minimizing if it's not a
hell yes it's no and we'll talk about
this maybe in another podcast but i have
these free for people that struggle with
saying how important is this next thing
what is that mario lopez
what does she have at 1 30 in pasadena
amazon
god damn it well they should send a jet
they should have sent a chopper
okay i'm sure there's an amazon driver
at my gate right now
we can throw her in the back and get her
to pasadena they can give me eyeliner in
20 minutes they can get her to pasadena
um okay i am going to shut up because
there's so much more uh i want to say
but i really don't want to take
advantage of your time and um i don't
want to bully you um i hope you'll maybe
come back i would love to come back i've
so enjoyed this conversation it's been
absolutely
wonderful i don't know what's the right
word fantastic great it's made me very
happy it's definitely made me very happy
i
am
i'm crestfallen i didn't get half of
what i wanted to ask out i i before you
came on we walked around and hung out
for a bit and had i know it was so fun
um i know we got to hang out a little
bit before off camera but there was so
much more i wanted to talk about with
you on camera because i think um you
speaking just heals people and i think
that something i do know that feels good
is being of service and we're both
trying to make things that you know we
wish were maybe available to us when we
were younger and this is going to change
so many people's lives um and uh i mean
i was laughing out loud at this book
it's unbelievable and yesterday i
brought it to a set that i was working
on people were losing their minds like
how did you get that so many everybody
brought it up yeah they're like it's
sold out how did you get that book like
this is
i hope you
feel good i do i appreciate it so much
and the title is fucking brilliant
you're brilliant everything's i love you
so much okay don't write elephants more
to come
oh anything else i mean this is great
don't buy a book they're out
you can't buy it anywhere love you
[Music]
[Applause]